Sally sells seashells by the seashore
sells seashells by the seashore
Sally Sally sells seashells by the
seashore
Sally sells seashells by the seashore
and Sally was a real person this is Mary
Anning
she sold rare invertebrate fossils by
the seashore
born in 1799 Mary was something
exceptionally rare for a woman at the
time possibly because as an infant she
was struck by lightning no she really
was she was a paleontologist of fossil
hunter if you will when she was 12
Mary dug up a 200 million year old
marine reptile the edge' saw a skeleton
translation she discovered the first
complete fish lizard ever throughout her
life she discovered tons of fossils and
sold rare invertebrates here by the
seashore of England's Jurassic Coast
unfortunately Mary lived in a time where
men ruled the roost and many of them
routinely took credit for her findings
but even though she might not have
gotten the kudos she deserved while
alive she has gone down in history as
the greatest fossil as the world ever
knew she was even selected as one of the
three most important female scientists
in Britain and inspired a tongue twister
that's one for the history books Sally
sells seashells by the seashore
no weren't you listening Mary's sold
fossils by the sea shop
you
[Music]